so it's dating then like give me the
oversight of dating is it like
weird ah to date again so weird
i'm not very good at dating i'm i'm not
good at dating either who's good at
dating
a dater i'm kind of like oh you're my
human now
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast on
the show today is ali
webb she is of course the founder of dry
bar which started the whole
craze to go get your hair done she said
that it started because
people wanted to go get their hair done
a couple of times a week so they didn't
have to do it themselves and
you know i mean at the end of the day
it's just nice when somebody plays with
your hair at least i like it it's a
great
great way to have a little girls night
out go get your hair done at you know
dry bar and go out to dinner and grab
some drinks and
we had a great conversation about a lot
about growing like growing as a human
being and
the the trials and tribulations of life
and what it throws at you
and just because just because someone is
accomplishing really great things
doesn't mean that they aren't struggling
and so we we talked about that today we
talked about um
talked about the things that she's been
going through and um
and where she's uh where she's looking
to expand
as a person and to grow stronger
but one thing's for sure dry bar is
going strong 130 locations and growing
so
please enjoy this episode today i really
enjoyed talking to ali and having a very
meaningful conversation
this is really cool for me because
obviously well you're you
arrive and the girl that's here
is the girl stephanie who's my friend
who set us up for the first time
in scottsdale that was like 2012.
gosh isn't that so i mean dry bar had
only been going then for
two years and so there was a location
downtown phoenix
and i remember my friend stephanie said
oh she didn't even know
it was like you you that was doing my
hair she's just like some
like main girl is going to come and do
your hair i'm like a main girl
some like important main person and so i
get there and then
i don't even know right at first and
then i'm like holy holy [ __ ] you own the
whole damn thing
yeah i think yeah cause i think as i was
doing your hair i was kind of telling
you who i was yeah
like oh but you were telling me who you
were too
because i was like had no they told me
they're like danica patrick is coming in
and i was like
who's that and they're like she's this
really famous race car driver and she's
amazing and i was like oh that's so cool
and then yeah yeah you started a craze
girl i know
there's all kinds of them now i mean
they've got all kinds i mean there's
a lot of copycats there are we have 130
locations is it around 30 now so we're
pretty far ahead
yeah and yeah there's definitely a
secret sauce
that is hard to emulate in my humble
opinion
what's that yeah what's up what is that
the secret sauce
well i mean first of all this this
business is rooted
you know with somebody who me who has
spent
20 plus years doing hair i mean i grew
up in south florida where
there's so much humidity in the air that
and i had curly hair and it was just
always so unruly and frizzy and you have
curly hair
i have naturally curly hair i wouldn't
if i didn't have curly hair we probably
wouldn't be sitting here because drybar
would never have been a thing
because as a kid in florida i
hated my hair because it was just crazy
and big and
and i just didn't understand how like
you know
the models of that time like you know
cindy crawford and
christy brinkley um which i'm probably
you know aging myself no you're right on
par i mean i'm right there yeah
you know they had this like beautiful
bouncy straight hair and i was like how
in the world do they get their hair like
to look like that and i remember looking
through magazines and being like
how did people make their hair look like
this and it was this thing the seed that
was planted in me truly all those years
ago
and i used to beg my mom to blow out my
hair and she wasn't a hairstylist and
she would do i would get so mad i mean i
literally have photos of her blow drying
my hair
and i'd be like there's a ridge like you
missed if you like she wasn't great at
it
you're a perfectionist but i was a
perfectionist even all those years ago
and
so you know the the seed was really
planted then and
then i spent you know high school and so
many we were in fact
right like i mean that was kind of your
first thing so it makes sense that
you're talking about models because
you were in fashion for a while and that
was the first time you worked with your
brother michael
yes and then then you went to hair
school when you're like 21 right yeah so
i
out of college i really didn't know what
i wanted to do and my friends all had
majors and i was all
i was like how do you know what you want
to do and i really didn't know and
but i did go to college for like a
second and then i ended up going to well
i never went at all so in fact i have a
ged so i'm not
judging it all yeah i know and i love
telling people that and what's ironic to
me is how much i get asked to speak at
college
oh my god cheers to that like i'm like i
get asked to get to do the uh
i get asked to do the uh commencement
speeches and i'm like i don't really
think i have a good place for that
i mean i have a ged i'm gonna probably
tell the kids this is a waste of money
yeah
i know i mean when when i've been not
always unless you're a doctor
yes i mean there's some things you
probably need to go to college for but
yeah no it wasn't it wasn't for me and i
went to fashion school i went for
fashion marketing and
you know and i i loved that and i then i
ended up working in fashion in
in new york city and then i kind of just
realized it wasn't for me
and i was working with my brother
michael at the time
and you know now he's my partner again
but you know i must have been 20
i don't know 21 22 when i decided to go
to beauty school which was like
clearly the best decision i ever made
but it felt like that in the moment what
happened like what
why why prompted it yeah like well my
brother and i
were running a couple of nicole miller
boutiques in south florida which we had
we were both working for nicole miller
in new york city and then we moved back
to south florida and opened a couple
boutiques and i was like
you know 20 something running these two
retail operations and i was like this
can't be it
like i this is not the rest of my life
like this is not what i want to be doing
and
michael and i started fighting a lot and
i think it's just because like neither
one of us
were doing what we really want to be
doing with our lives and so i said
i think i'm gonna go to beauty school
and he and he was very supportive of
that he was like
you're great with people you love hair i
think that's perfect for your own
yeah and i had kind of you know gotten
better at my hair but still wasn't great
at it but i
i just loved your hair today yes it
looks great thank you
did you use a wand like a flat iron or
did you use an actual
three-day
don't worry i buy your stuff anyway okay
and it smells so good
but the flat iron curl thing that i did
today i lost a lot of like yeah yeah
i lost a lot of hair today oh no yeah
well i'm not very good at yet because
it's sure it's
new for me the key is small sections
small clothes you're
totally right because i think that's
what everybody does wrong i'm
quite certain of it everybody takes a
massive section and like well it's like
it should be one to two inches and be
very clean
and then you won't lose hair but the fun
iron curls are good because they
actually stay and i know your hair and
your hair is very very straight so
getting the flat iron curls is good for
you my hair is naturally curly so
for me it's uh the three-day bender but
anyway okay
i um where was i well you went to beauty
school
and you loved doing hate you know you
liked it and you got better at it
and it's like it was beautiful was it
just was it hair was it makeup too
it wasn't makeup i don't think but you
did learn manicures and
like the whole thing yeah and cut and
color i i ended up cutting hair for a
long time but i swear i went to beauty
school to learn how to
learn how to blow out my own hair
however when i was in high school i
worked at a hair salon as a receptionist
and they used to blow out my hair and i
would just like be fascinated
studying them in the mirror like how do
they do it i was so
i mean it it could not be more perfect
that i do what i do and i'm who i am
because
truly it was like this thing that
mystified me for so many years i was so
into
hair and blow out so well you obviously
got in so deep yeah
well you did that but then you did hair
and then when you wanted to have a
family i'm like it's all coming together
now
why your company was uh straight at home
straight at home and i was like why did
she call her company straight at home
but you want to have kids and so then
you started kind of doing something you
know that was like your side hustle
to like be at home and yet still do a
little bit
yeah yeah it was called straight at home
and i always wondered why and it's
totally because he wanted straight hair
my whole life i was like i just want
straight hair and i was always mystified
by the girls
whose hair just grew out of their head
straight which i actually know
technically why that happens now
because i researched everything there is
to know about hair um
and like my sister-in-law my brother's
wife her hair sticks straight and i just
always kind of hated those girls well
can you tell me i want my why mine has a
wave in the back then
it's straight well it's interesting
because it's like basically the way your
hair grows out of your head
is is how it is how like the your hair
gets the
whether your hair is going to be
straight or wavy or curly gets
determined so
well for you it's very normal for
people's hair to grow in different ways
so when i sleep at night and it's like
not i still do it even when i have
short hair now but for long hair i i
take my hair
and it goes above me when i go to sleep
like on your pillow on a
like so the long end is up high yeah
above the pillow
yeah and so it's not i'm not laying on
my hair and it's not down by my side do
you sleep on a silk pillowcase
no that would help things okay yeah
because but is it because i'm like the
back of my head like like it gets curly
like the hair
it's like up it go it's late it lays
like this yeah so the back of my head's
really wavy but the rest is pretty
straight so what happens when you wake
up
oh it just it's like grown like that
like it's a perma wave like that that's
that that that thing is like
it's so it's like i got a perm i feel
like most women have
pockets of their hair like i always
thought it was hormones i don't i don't
know [ __ ] i mean i think that
hormones potentially
change the way your hair over texture
maybe yeah 100
but and as you get older your hair
changes a lot and i don't know if this
is actually true i believe it to be true
that every seven years your hair
changes i think that's true there's a
thing that you change as a human being
every seven years like taste buds
all kinds of stuff every seven years you
get divorced
i got divorced literally on the set
seven years to the day
i got married i remember when we were at
seven years my now ex-husband and i
remember thinking like
yeah no it's i don't think that's real i
got the 16-year age
oh i think you got way back you did the
double you doubled down
yeah there's probably some transition
time at the end so i'm gonna call it the
14.
you know you did a double yeah i did a
double yeah
um but but yeah i mean i think the
reason
back to your earlier question that you
know we're so far ahead of the game
from the copycats it's just because of
this like deep deeply rooted love i have
had for hair and so
yeah i've worked in hair salons i've
worked in the industry for so many years
that i was so uniquely qualified to do
something like this and when we started
in 2010 there was nothing like dry bar
that's so crazy to me that you i mean to
maybe it's crazy to think what it is now
to look and see that it went from a
company that was straight at home
in 2009 to dry bar in 2010 yeah but you
started like what um
why did you first off why did you decide
what made it time for a brick and mortar
like what made it time for
a real salon well i was operating this
mobile business straight at home and and
you know it was it was somewhat of a
whim of an idea there was no
like i wasn't trying to build a big
business i was trying to get
away from my kids for a couple of hours
you know during the day
or something for myself and because
adult conversations yeah
and and because i had spent so many
years in hair and i was like this will
be like a piece of cake for me and
um so how often were you doing like how
many so i put up
my my ex-husband who's like the creative
of dry bar he made me
a one-page website i came up with the
name straight at home which i was
quite proud of i thought it like really
checked all the boxes right because
you're going straight to your home well
straight at your home
straight hair at your home yeah i'll
come over when your baby's sleeping i
you know i put up this like one page
website i went to like all like the
mommy
groups all over town and i was like i'll
come over while your baby's sleeping
for yoga class you're like here you go
here you go but it was what was amazing
and i think like the marketer and
entrepreneur in me
was so excited to start getting the
calls and that's what happened is i
started getting
you know calls to come to women's home
you know women i didn't know and i
started building up this this business
where i was like
i really you know in theory i don't
think i actually made any money i was
charging forty dollars a client in
between
gas and driving all that yeah and like
my nissan xterra with the duffel bag in
the back seat
you know i i was doing maybe two to
three
clients a day like it was nothing yeah
but it grew really fast and i started
getting calls and i really
was saying no way more than i was saying
yes because i still had to pick up my
kids from preschool and
i you know i just like the point of the
job was to be flexible yes
and so but but well you know i'm so
grateful that i did that and
for that experience because it so much
of that business has informed what
drybar ultimately became and
and i really realized during that time
when i was saying no to my clients my
question my next question to them was
always well what do you do where do you
go and they're like well
you know either go to like the fantastic
sam's like down the street which they
hated cause like the lighting is bad
it's like
the experience is bad you don't know
what you're getting or they would go to
their cotton color salon where they're
you know paying upwards of like 75 to 80
bucks for a blowout
yeah if not more and they were like
so i just don't do it and i was like
well that's a shame you know because
they loved it when they did it and it
gave them this extra boost of confidence
and they were really happy and so
that's when i went to my brother who's
bald and has
no business in the hair world and said
you know i want to turn
my mobile business into a brick and
mortar
and this was 2010 so or almost 2010 it
was the middle recession
you know most yeah most women got the
idea yeah most men were like this is the
craziest
thing like even my brother's first
response was like
why would a woman pay somebody else to
blow out their hair now this is 10 years
ago and i feel like men are a lot more
savvy about blowouts now but
but even still men are like what what's
a blowout but women got it and
i mean man we had to we had to
personally guarantee that first lease in
brentwood because the landlord was like
huh
everybody was like what the hell is this
concept and
my brother my brother had worked in real
estate marketing and he had a good
friend who was an architect this harvard
award-winning
architect who built you know million
dollar homes and you know he
might he was like my little sister has
an idea for uh like a hair salon concept
would you do it with us and he was he
was like kind of in between projects and
his name is josh heitler and he's still
to this day 10 years later builds all
our stores but
that's cool he was and we we couldn't
afford him we gave him a little bit of
equity and
and away we went and boom and it was
just this crazy thing and i remember
going to brentwood god i haven't thought
about this in so long but i remember
going to brentwood when we were under
construction
and the shopping center was dead like
there was there was nobody in sight no
women nothing and my brother was like
ally
what the [ __ ] where are where is
everybody and i was like
they're gonna come it's like we will
build a new building
and sure enough you know the first day
we opened we were booked solid
it was like i mean we hit the ground
running it was so
unbelievable to me it just totally shows
that it's your calling like it's meant
to be
it's it's you're in the flow of like
what was needing to happen you're
feeling into it
and like you trusted you had to believe
right i mean
i did i mean and i think that you know
the the
you know this the phrase ignorance is
bliss very much
to me you know i've i've always been a
little bit heavy in the clouds like i
don't really
i'm really bad about knowing what's
going on in the world yeah in the news
and i don't
i've never paid super close attention
that i'm not super proud of that but
it's just who i am and
when when we were looking at that first
location and everybody was like
you're crazy also a lot of people told
me the actual space we were looking at
at brentwood
i remember a woman coming to me and
being like you know every business
that's been here has failed i was like
thanks for that yeah but we're not going
to yeah and i was like
i really believe at least in my little
world
in la and the clients i had i really
believed that
women would pay 35 to look really great
and i thought that they would probably
go
longer in between cuts in color because
they you kind of camouflage it with a
really great blowout right
and that was it that was my belief and
that was my dream and that was my hope
and
just never power i'm believing i mean to
me there's a difference between like
like let's say for me in racing like oh
yeah i believe in you to like
no i really like know you're gonna do
this yeah and
yeah it's the same so you've had you
have p you have to have people around
you that do
and then you have to believe it but as
long as like one critical element person
really really truly believes something's
gonna happen it was the same thing with
my whole career like
there's no reason why i should have been
a professional race car driver i was
living in england i
came home i didn't do anything for
almost two years but for some dumb
reason
i still believed it was going to happen
i truly just you always want to do that
yeah i mean yeah i started racing when i
was 10. so like i just
truly believed that it was going to work
out yeah and that's it
so you believed in this you believed in
this
and there's magic in that like i tell
people like even when
there's an example of somebody let's say
who's has a family member that's sick
or something like that i'm like just
trust i'm like and really like picture
them getting well and really believe
they're going to like there's a magic in
the belief or if it's a company or
whatever it may be or a project or
it's funny how that i believe that too
this you know
as you know this has been a really tough
year for me personally so
you i kind of you kind of forget that
you know you forget that like oh yeah
you have to like believe
things are going to work out and things
are going to get better you know and at
that time
now you know 10 years ago i was so like
bright-eyed and like
i can do anything and as you get this
it is nice it is and as you get older
you're kind of like
oh well yeah [ __ ] life is hard you know
yeah
there's also a level like i mean maybe
you're similar but i i'm kind of getting
the
getting the feeling like you think this
way too that you kind of also don't
really give a [ __ ] what someone says
like if they're like oh that's not going
to work you're like yeah just
okay i don't care right or totally not
not i've never been like i'll show you
but i'm just like
your beliefs are not mine yeah yeah stop
it doesn't matter you're not
you're not affecting me in the slightest
yeah yeah yeah because we had a lot of
naysayers in the beginning and a lot of
people that just were like
yeah i don't get how this concept is
going to work i mean and in my mind
i knew that we had to do you know a
certain amount of blowouts and at that
time i was thinking if we could do 30 to
40 blocks a day
that would be a great business and now
that would be a terrible day i mean now
we're doing upwards of a hundred blocks
a day per store
for 130 she's like sometimes 130. a lot
of it's a lot of
hot air yeah that's my joke
um but yeah no it's just it's been such
a trip what was the magic sauce so now
we're now we're
now we're to actual salon yeah so i
think it was so what was the parts that
were like super
it's a lot you know it's definitely a
lot of things i mean again
i i i was obviously responsible for
hiring
and the stylist which in the beginning
there wasn't a whole lot of like
training that was in place that kind of
came with time once i realized like
you know i mean the stylist needed some
training and
that now we have a very robust training
program but i knew what to look for in
stylus and i also knew how to like
tell if clients were happy because i
knew what looked good and what didn't
and i also knew how to achieve it so i
could always step in and i could always
i mean and i spent like the first six
months in that first store
every single day from open to close i
mean i didn't really want to leave i was
like it was so intoxicating that like it
was so busy and crazy
um you know and then my parents were
entrepreneurs and they had their own
business so i
grew up in that world so i really
understood customer service
from like i i had such an education
growing up in my parents business
that i didn't even know i was getting at
the time but you know i watched my
parents bend over backwards for
customers and i watched how
their businesses thrived because of it
and that that was such an important
ingredient ingredient yeah
you know it's modeling and i'm such a
firm believer and you know i've had a
lot of before dry bar i had a lot of
like careers
and and i did a lot of things and i'm
such a firm believer and like you have
to really trust your path and
all of the things i've done every single
job i ever had
you know i started working i was like 16
and every single job i had i really
think
made me who i ultimately became i mean
even i was a publicist for
a couple years when i lived in new york
and that taught you about that part of
that yeah and i learned how to write and
be
like professional and all of that which
i eventually needed to be running a
company you know and
people try and worry too much about
where they're going and how they're
getting there and they're getting the
perfect job and i'm telling like just
get started yeah even if it's not the
right job it'll teach you something or
even
like and they weren't they were all not
the right jobs for me they were me
experimenting and
figuring out what i wanted to do and i
you know and if you were to look at me
and
you'd probably be and i remember feeling
a little
kind of judged and again not really
caring what people thought but i
jumped from thing to thing in my 20s in
career to career and i didn't know what
i wanted to do and i tried all these
things and like thank god that i did
even though it seemed a little like oh
what's ali doing and she's doing this
now and she's doing this now but i
learned so much and i wasn't like trying
to learn so much i mean
obviously like the the older wiser
version of me now
knows that that's what i was doing but
at the time i was just i was just
following like my heart i was following
my gut and i just was doing the thing
that made me happy at the
the time in that moment and it really
truly i believe made me
do you feel like you're someone who
lives in the present or
or the past or the future like give me
your tense of thinking like i'm someone
who lives in the future like i'm
i have a goal in mind but you sound
pretty good at flowing
yeah i think i try to live in the
present i try to enjoy the moment but in
terms of like
the future i i think i do i'm really
trying to not do this i'm trying to work
on not
being worried about what's coming next
and enjoy what's now you know
and i think that like probably my
perspective has shifted because
i went from being married you know i
mean that's just kind of i mean i'm in
the very like personal
growth phase of my life um because i
spent the last 10 years so head
heads down building my business and
raising little kids that i am now like
hey i like need a minute for myself here
and now that you know i spent 16 years
with this one person
and then not and i don't have that
person anymore and it was
it was very jarring like to readjust all
that and i'm like well so
what happens like do i do i stay single
forever do i date again do i get married
again like
and so i am trying to not put so much
emphasis on that i'm trying to just live
in the moment and enjoy
because i'm where i want to be and this
is what i wanted i wanted like a kind of
a second
shot at like not to sound so cheesy but
like love and romance and all of that
and so i was like
that's what i'm gonna do but now that
i'm in that i'm like oh crap
[ __ ] am i gonna be alone forever like am
i going to remarry am i going to have it
out of control
it's a little like you know it feels
very unsettling well but fun too
it's a weird place to be it's cool and i
want to talk more about that for sure um
but what did like so you go from
like not working to being a mom to all
of a sudden now you're there
well working to being a mom well working
to being a mom
kind of working not yeah not really
working kind of working
loving what you're doing and now you
have a business and you're working every
single day so
this like uh you you opened up the
floodgates yes and so
did that cause tension because you went
from basically going
wait hang on this was supposed to be a
side side job and now the sudden i never
see you
yeah my life completely turned upside
down and i had to i mean drive our dry
bar
like was a bomb yeah it just exploded it
exploded and
thank god that i you know my mom my i
grew up in south florida
my parents divorced when i when they
were my mom was in her late 50s and
we kind of like inherited my mom and she
kind of lived we
kind of moved her wherever we moved once
i had my second son which is
so grateful for that because she was
always there to be with the kids
and thank god she was i really don't
know what would have happened if she
wasn't because
i was so excited and it was so like
intoxicating that
we had you know started this business it
was just
thriving it was like lightning in a
bottle i mean we just felt like we were
on this
rocket ship and it was awesome and but i
had two little kids and so i was like
yeah
i didn't i wasn't comfortable leaving
with the nanny all the time oh yeah so
much guilt i mean
so your mom watched them so my mom did
your ex-husband watch them a lot too or
well he was in he was doing the same
thing he was in the thrust in the
business as well and he was doing all
the
creative and i mean when we first
started the business he was
a creative agent the creative director
of the advertising agency which is a
very demanding job i wonder why all your
stuff looks so damn yeah she's so good
i mean so good like your branding is the
best
it's so good and everything i would love
to see a company squeeze like i'm like
god who does her branding it's
amazing well you can now hire him okay
he has started his own business
oh but the way it started obviously his
calling he's good at it yeah he's so
good at it he's just
amazing at that and he was working at an
advertising agency and then like
at night working on dry bar and that
really went on even for the first year
or two after we started dry bar until
dry bar was able to like bring him
in-house right
you know fast forward now this last year
he kind of
went out on his own and started his own
agency right which has dry bar as a
client and our new business squeeze and
then he'll probably
see and then he does some a couple of
other things he won't take on a lot of
clients
but yeah i mean he's you know he was it
was an interesting time because
he we were both incredibly busy doing
very different things which by the way
is why
the three of us our partnership worked
so well because my brother was really
the business side of things and
cam was the creative and i was the hair
and yeah you know so it
really worked incredibly well but thank
god for my mom and and i think it was i
think it was a lot of strange
marriage because i was like i was the
i'd be very quickly became the face of
the company oh yeah and i had to go
i had to travel all the time so he still
was home with the kids a lot
uh and it was a definitely a shift in a
lot of ways
in roles in the marriage because you
know he had always been
the breadwinner he was the one who was
working and i was home with the kids and
then all of a sudden i wasn't home with
the kids and he was going home with the
kids and i was kind of
the breadwinner and that just i mean
that's difficult for us a lot and
he was okay with it i think i think me
traveling a lot
was really the biggest issue even worse
just being gone being gone so why why is
that
i think it was um i think it was just
it's i mean you don't have you don't
have kids no no kids i mean it
i think just being with two little kids
for anybody is just
a lot i mean two dogs are driving me
freaking nuts i'm like i literally like
the girlfriend my girlfriends were
leaving i'm like
can you take the dogs over these dogs i
feel like a mom with kids and i'm like i
can't
deal with it i'm like spazzing out i'm
like yelling at them
today and i'm like i feel like a parent
who that's how it is like a single
parent with a couple of
like rascals that just won't won't calm
down by the way
i mean so that's so now you don't have
help like right and you know it's like
it's like that's how cam felt you know
he's like i don't love being a single
dad
yeah the irony is now he is for real
but you know he didn't he didn't like
having to be you know not that he didn't
like being with the kids but it's just
also like two young kids is like as hard
as it gets you know i mean now we have
like two teenagers and that's easier
because they can take care of themselves
a lot more when
when you have little kids and one's
still in diapers it's just
and they're always going this direction
it's a lot and i know it because i was
doing it too and i was like well i
stayed home with them by myself all the
time like it's your turn now i know when
you hear a guy going like
i did a mommy day i'm like i do every
day like that
yeah exactly and and so it did put a lot
of strain
on the marriage and we were just so busy
in time to communicate through it or was
it something where you felt like
it was hard to find time to even do that
yeah i don't i mean
obviously we ended up in divorce so we
clearly didn't do something right but
um i mean there was a lot of other
things well not everyone that comes into
our life is meant to stay i believe that
i believe that too
i wholeheartedly believe that i've
learned more about myself
in this last year from dating people
that i didn't i didn't know and by the
way the whole like seven years
every seven years you changed like i
believe that's true i met my husband
when i was
26 i'm 44 now i mean the amount of
changes i've gone through in that time
is is pretty crazy yeah and you know i
i just couldn't be more different than i
was when i met him
and i'm just such a different person in
so many ways and things that i want for
myself and
out of a relationship and all of that
stuff is just
completely different you know you just
change so much
so what has that been like in the last
year tell me about that tell me about
what the growth looks like
well what have you put yours what
difficult positions have you put
yourself in what
what are you
what are you trying to face well
i mean i think it's like perhaps it's
like a little mid-life crisis
ish i don't know there's you know i
think that
go even though you know i think that um
it was good that we broke up we split up
um i i didn't anticipate the like the
energy
of not having that person around and
what that would be like you know there
was that
you always have that per person yeah the
loss and i remember people saying to me
it's a death and i was like
yeah no it's not like that yeah until i
realized it was and i found myself kind
of in a bit of a depression for
you know which i actually love talking
about this stuff because
i don't think people talk about it
enough and i think there's so many
mental health issues in this country
that people don't
face and they just medicate and they
don't talk about the things and
i did all the things you know i went on
i went to this crazy retreat in
nashville
where you like give up your phone for a
week and you do intensive therapy i went
to like reiki healers i still do that i
started doing transcendental meditation
because i was so faced down for for so
long and i
i was so in this depression which really
blindsided me i mean that's the thing i
think
i i was blindsided in so many ways that
i didn't
i just didn't i didn't see coming
obviously and um
and and just like readjusting to this
new life and this new
you know being a single mom and living
by myself
and not having that like person that i
always had to check in with to just tell
about my day
you know the highs and lows that person
that you share that stuff with
and i think that being gone and bouncing
business ideas off of that and i have
an amazing group of friends that really
stepped up
for me during that time and thank god
for that and you know i'm super close
with my brother you know my mom passed
away three years ago
oh wow that kind of was like
that was kind of hard and i don't think
i ever really dealt with that and then
one's like we're gonna have to yeah
gonna have to ally
once the divorce happened i think it all
just culminated in this like
i just kind of fell into this like deep
depression
where i had to like i was like what is
happening to me and
and i had to like did you feel like you
get out you were i didn't know who i was
i was so lost and it was the first time
since like probably i was just like high
school when i was when i like i was
saying before when all my friends
decided to go to college and they knew
what their majors were and i felt very
lost
it was it was like if i could equate it
to something it's probably more like
that where i'm like i am
so lost in my life right now like
and i don't know who i am and i don't
know what i want i don't know what i
want to do with this next chapter
and that's such a like you know it's
such a um
like disconcerting uneasy feeling you
know
so you know i spent the last year it was
the first step what was the first i
think the first step the first step to
like
realizing it then realizing who you were
and what you wanted i think um
i think it was like it was a lot of like
soul-searching and
you know taking time to like
you know put on the brakes and figure
out what i wanted to do and
try to refocus and um you know i don't i
don't i don't know
that there was a first step i think it
was like a combination of things
that i started like being like you gotta
get like yourself i mean i
i started reaching out to lots of
different people and i think because of
like the void
with my mom i think i found myself you
know reaching out to like
certain women in my life who were older
and like represented older than me and
represented like a mom
like i i you know somewhere similar to
how i met you i met maria shriver
and um katherine schwarzenegger is a
friend of mine and so i
remember reaching out to maria and she
was like get out of bed
do this do that and ta-da and i was like
okay you know and she
scared the [ __ ] out of me and she's like
you have to you know she's like it's not
uncommon what you're going through it's
like women who get divorced after
being married to someone for so long
yeah it's just this is so normal you
have to just
be there for your kids and you have to
get up and it's like you just kind of
have to go and like
you got to just get back out there and
you know and face the world and
you know and there's there was a few
women like that that came into my life
and i just started like
you know you know figuring out like and
started like going to therapy regularly
and that's where i started like
i found a couple of girlfriends of mine
who had also been through divorce and
things like that they're like
transcendental meditation has like saved
my life i did that
you know tell me more about that i'd
love to get more in it's amazing and and
i had
tried meditation and i oh you know i
mean i'm sure
when you most people try it you know
your brain is like all over you
nobody feels like they do it right
everybody's like i don't know if i'm
doing it right well there's no real
outfit there's no right or wrong yeah
but i think the idea behind meditation
is to
shut your brain off and like
stop thinking that you know but which is
practically impossible because if you
say stop thinking it's
all you do if like don't think of the
pink elephant i'm thinking i'm not
thinking yeah exactly
so the thing about transcendental
meditation that resonated with me so
much is that you know
you go through this like training they
really talk to you about it and the
thing about it
is the way they explained it to me and
being such a visual person that it
really
resonated i remember them showing me a
picture of like
um a brain that is in fight or flight
mode
which which is basically as humans we
operate
was it colors like red like color yeah
we we
operate from the frontal cortex of our
brain okay and that's where that's the
ceo of our brain so that's where we make
good decisions and we like weigh things
out and like that's that's the good part
when you're in fight flight or fight
flight or fight mode which is like if a
bear is chasing you
sure all that blood like rushes and you
don't
and you're just making a decision based
on like oh [ __ ]
like i'm in trouble i gotta make a
decision and they showed me a picture of
like a brain
in that fight-or-flight mode which is
like there's no blood for very little
blood flow coming here
and it's all back there so you're all at
your brain your brain and your chemicals
are all out of whack and so
the fit and don't quote me on that
that's how i
interpreted it someone might be watching
and be like that's not exactly what it
is so
whatever that we're no doctors here no
no no no no claiming here
but that's how i interpreted it and
basically what the transcendental
meditation does is like it transcends
you
and helps your brain truly like calm
down and it transcends you which i know
sounds like weird and trippy but
the first time i did it and then i
started doing it what
they give you a mantra that is like very
specific to you
and you can't tell anybody and it's just
yours and you repeat the mantra over and
over again it's not words though right
it's a sound it's like oh
oh okay like something like that is
sound
but it's not words okay but some
somewhere
okay okay and so you repeat this over
and over again and you have to see
someone special for that you have to go
to get trained on it okay yeah like
there's a place in la called the david
lynch foundation okay where
that's where i went i think you could
hire like a private person to do it too
but you
you have to go it's like about four
hours so you go for i went four hours a
week one day
monday tuesday wednesday oh okay four
hours straight i'm like i don't need a
snack in there i don't know it's like
four hours um and you go monday through
thursday which is like
i was like i i will do it i'd like like
i'll have this done in four hours yes i
will like
so you when you're meditating you
it is this bizarre thing and as someone
who not
has never really meditated i i was like
i
again i was like i will do anything to
feel better
you know and i didn't want to go on
antidepressants just for me like i'm
just for you i'm very sensitive to that
stuff which by the way
you're talking about medicating a lot
yeah i did not want to do that
so i with the meditation it
it literally like the best way you can
describe it is it like something
transcends in you and it's almost like
it's almost like you go to sleep but you
don't but you're
it's like you come out of it you do it
for 20 minutes twice a day
and you come you come out of it which
i've like slacked on a little bit lately
but
you come out of it and you're like i was
i know i wasn't asleep
but i wasn't awake okay where the [ __ ]
was i sorry
yeah yeah it is weird either in that and
you come out and and they say it's a
there's an accumulative
effect and which is also like hard to
wrap my head around
but i you know the more you the more you
do it
and i'll tell you even my kids noticed
and my kids were like you don't get as
mad as you used to get
there is a calmness about me well i need
to try that then you 100
[ __ ] i think everybody on the planet
should do it there's such a calmness
about me that i've never had like i've
always had like road rage
do you have road rage no yes i'm always
like
um by the way i just got not to like
name drop cars but i just
got a porsche for the first time oh nice
and i'm like i just want to drive it
so fast the car or the suv it's the
cayenne
nice and and i realized i cuz i went
somewhere to test drive i can recommend
some roads to take
well they told me they have this like
track that you can like somewhere that
you can just right
i was like i want to do that so bad
let's take decker canyon road right here
and that'll get you there too
um because i'm a bit of an aggressive
driver which i feel like you would
appreciate definitely going to talk
why are you driving so slow and but you
know there's just like a um
this like intensity about me which i
think i still have but
that the the tm has really like calmed
me
down so i think it was like a reset it
is a bit of a reset and when you're
doing it all the time
there i can just feel it i am different
than i used to be and there's a
there's a calmness about me and there's
a piece with me that i didn't use to
have well you said cumulative and it
makes me think of cumulative on the
other side of things which is where
things build up things build up things
build up things build up and so
you know i think of it like it's almost
easier to me associate like if you can
just get back to neutral or like
reset back at zero again even if you
accumulate through the day which you're
going to you're never going to get to
where you'd be if you never did it at
all which is like continuously breaking
and getting edgy and you're never
objecting
and you yeah and that's the thing you
release it in ways that are really
unfair right right you're snapping at
people and things and
you know one of the things they i
remember them saying about the
transcendental two is that like
if you really do it regularly you really
can purge
deep like you can get stuff that's been
like built up in you have you felt that
before
i i mean i just i think the like i said
like i just feel like
there's i'm just i've changed so much
you know it's really helped me
like just calm down and help me like
deal with things better and
not get i don't i just don't think i get
like as mad i don't think i have like a
lot of anger and
i and as for as hard as things got with
my ex-husband
even like when he did things that i
think normally i would have like really
freaked out about
haven't i just like i don't really get
angry and if you don't have to go
through the purge process then good for
you but i mean i've in my life
had that where like it does feel like a
purge or like i was just talking about
my friend it feels it's like convulsions
almost well i feel like i
purged like cry like well no i did that
probably
i feel like i've i feel like i cried for
a year
you know i feel like i cried i have
cried
so much and i remember like my therapist
being like and everybody's saying i'm
sure you heard this like you the only
way
through it the way you feel the other
and so i was like i don't want to go
through i want to go around
what i said yeah i said i just want to
go to sleep and wake up in three months
that's what i want to do yeah and but i
really like the through everything i
read
um there's a great book untethered soul
oh
no it's a good book it's really good i
mean i read a lot during this time
and because so much of what i was being
told by like all these like kind of like
spiritual leaders and people i was like
meeting and talking to was like
you have to go through it yeah you have
to feel it
and of course my response to that was
like i don't want to feel it it feels
terrible of course you have to i
remember them saying to me too you have
to surrender to it and i was like i
don't want to surrender to it
and i remember i'll stand up to you yeah
yeah you just want to fight it your ego
is a real bastard yeah
real bastard yeah and i remember being
like
i give up like i i just i remember and
there it was and and i think i just
and it's almost it's such a like that
feeling
is is now a little bit of a distant
memory
and i remember it but fade's quick it's
quick and but i remember feeling
like i wanted to die i was just gonna
say i remember when i
was going through it i was retiring
breaking up with my boyfriend of five
years
and moving all within days yeah and i
knew it was coming
yeah and i seriously felt like i wanted
to like i was dying
yeah that's how i felt too and it's so
similar for me too because
you know we're 10 years into the
business we have a professional ceo we
have all these people running the
company i'm not in the weeds the way i
used to be yeah so my
my role shifted a lot even though i'm
still like responsible for so much
with the company i'm not i'm not in the
weeds my like whole identity
was all messed up oh man it was all in
limbo it was all over
my marriage ended i was a single mom i
was like now living by myself and that's
how i felt too i mean i
literally and i remember talking to a
couple of girlfriends
you know who kind of been through
similar things and them saying they felt
like in that time in their life they
wanted to die too and i was like
okay it's not just me and that yeah and
that's why again like i like talking
about this stuff because i think people
need to
understand that they're not like crazy
if they feel that way
but that's how i felt i was like i just
like i don't want to like i didn't like
i don't want to die it just felt like i
was dying yeah it was like i just you
were you were dying to that old yeah my
girlfriend i was just talking this it's
like it's like
you have to let the old person die the
old you see i think this is my concept
on
change anyway is that change is hard
because it means you're going to have to
mourn something yeah
it's the death of something and so it's
not that you're actually
not looking for the future you're
leaving your husband like you and your
husband are separating for a reason
you're transitioning through things for
a reason
right you're asking for this you're
calling for this but what you are going
to have to deal with
is the death of never again this never
do
that never live here never wake up with
them again
never there's only so many nevers again
that
that's the deaths that you have to
endure and deal with and
cope and and and grasp and like cry
through
yeah and that the change is that that's
the hard part about change not because
you're actually scared of the changes
because the changes are for the better
right
i mean that's the point right right no i
know and now you know and now it's so
interesting
you know you know dating and being like
oh you know though that there's a lot of
shifting and changing there too and
you're like oh
you know it's just like and you're right
that's such a good way to put it because
like
you know when things change it's hard
and you and you even though like you're
making a change because you ultimately
know
in your gut it's the right thing it's
not easy and you're like
you know it's it's it's what did you
learn about yourself
well i think i learned that i'm
you know much more like resilient than i
probably thought i was
you know you seem pretty resilient
anyway though yeah i mean
even more i mean i think that i you know
i i think i've just
um
yeah it's it's it's a good question no
one's really asked me that you know what
what what have i learned about myself um
do you have different patterns
i think do you have different routines i
think yeah i realized we're important to
you yeah i think i learned
that like you know um
i think in terms of like learning things
about myself like i learned that i
you know i do like i i was in this kind
of
i want to say like you know i didn't i
didn't put a lot of emphasis
on my relationship and on love and on
that kind of stuff and i think i missed
i mean i'm it's sad you know and i and
i'm
i i think i missed out on that
because i was so focused on the business
and the kids
and that i didn't take care of what i
needed for myself
for so many years i heard something just
the other day from this lady who gave me
a facial who's basically like
a total intuitive the facial was a
byproduct like that yeah
i can give her i would like to see her
um yeah you'll probably just cry through
it
because she's just like she's telling
you [ __ ] and you're like what
um but she said for me she was like
describing my situations and stuff i was
dealing with and she said
what i'm seeing is she's like
the the focus is the distraction
right so you think you're being great
right you think you're being so focused
and you're being so committed to
something
you're like i'm doing a great job but
the focus is the distraction
yeah well it's i was like whoa that
couldn't be more spot on for me
because i was so focused on building dry
bar and raising my children
and that was it and i didn't put any
attention to the fact that like i wasn't
really happy
underneath it all in in terms of i mean
i was happy in a lot of ways because i
was like
so proud of this business that we built
and so proud of all the jobs we created
and i can't
it's like and i'm so incredible yeah
that and my children are
will be the best things i ever did but
i never stopped to think about my own
like personal happiness
those were outside of you yeah and and
yeah
and now and so i finally did you know
and a year ago i decided to make that
change and i think that's the biggest
thing about myself is like
you know and not to get like too into
the weeds here but i do not go there i
didn't think i was like a very
affectionate person like i didn't think
i needed that i didn't
think i needed that like from another
human being i was like
so independent so like i don't know it
just like it was like shut
off me for so many years and now i'm
like
oh i would like to like really
experience that
that would be good again oops i forgot
about that you know
and so i think that's like the biggest
thing i learned was that i'm like you
know
pretty like intuitive like emotionally
driven person and even like even i
discovered it like with like my
friendships like my best friend paige
has been my best friend since our babies
were we met when our
our now 14 year old sons were babies in
like a breastfeeding support group
and you know and she was always like
you're uh you've
our whole friendship even in a
friendship you know i'm
i was always a little arm's length like
not very intimate as a person i don't
think
i never even like thought about the word
intimacy like i didn't even really know
what it meant like
and i don't think i ever like embraced
intimacy in any way shape or form and
and i remember her kind of telling me
that about our friendship and i was like
what do you want me to do like
lay in bed with you like i don't what
what does that even mean
and then through this divorce the
process like oh i understand now what
intimacy and it is and i think i would
actually like to have that in my life
you know yeah real real root is like
vulnerability
it is and then and somebody told me
about brene brown oh of course and
which is wonderful she's amazing which
you know therein lies like the craziness
of my life because
i going through this really hard time
someone tells me to watch a brene brown
talk
i don't even think i knew what i don't
even know if the word vulnerable was in
my vocabulary i didn't like i didn't
really
google all that damn word
what does that even mean i know i'd go
to type it on my phone
why isn't it projected i'm not even
close enough to project the right hours
listen my spell check is so messed up on
my phone that it spells words wrong
yeah and just absolutely you know what's
funny for me
is anytime i try to write the word just
it uh it populates to hair
what the hell does that mean isn't that
ironic but
i yeah so i got turned on to brene brown
and
i started i watched one of her things
and i was like whoa
blown away and on a whim just because
so many women love drybar i i went to dm
her
on instagram and had a dm from her
what to me inviting me to a lunch holy
moly apparently
i i mean it was crazy it was the
craziest thing and it was such a nice
little like because you probably just
started following her then and then you
looked and just you saw the message yeah
is it too outdated to make it in time
for the lunch
yes totally missed the lunch but i
reached out to her
talk about vulnerable at this point i
was like so desperate i'll do anything
i'll say anything to anybody and i was
like oh my god i just watched one of
your talks
you're so amazing i'm going through a
divorce i feel like i want to die and
blah blah and she wrote back to me
and we started talking she gave me her
cell i called her using
i was like and i didn't really realize
what a big deal she was at that moment i
just was like this is this amazing woman
on the internet who's like
you know talks about vulnerability and
then you know we've seen oprah seems to
like her and oprah
i'm like who who do i think i am and we
like have become friends and like
well if your phone goes missing for a
hot second after this is over with it's
because i'm trying to find herself
i mean it just was like and i learned so
much more and i would text her all the
time what did she teach you what was the
what did you take away
she was very much a big like listen you
have to go through it you have to feel
it damn it everybody she's not what i
want you to tell me give me like
because that was what i was running
around being like how do i fix it
how do i get better what do i do you
know and she and she was one of those
people who was like
you have to feel it you have to go
through it i know it sucks i mean i
remember her texting me like i know this
[ __ ] sucks like
and i'd be like but i you know i feel
this i feel like she's like i know you
just have to feel like you're doing
great
you're doing great keep going you know
go that's a sign you're on the right
and she was the one who told me about
this retreat in nashville because her
friend miles
was the ceo and and again these are like
very surreal moments that probably don't
happen to a lot of people so i realize
how lucky i am she was like
she's like i have an idea if you were
open to it and she she's like i'm gonna
have my friend miles who's the ceo of
this place
called onsite in nashville call you i
was like okay
and he called me he the ceo of this
place calls me the next day and he's
like and he's
the sweetest guy and i'm like hysterical
never talked to this guy in my life and
i'm like and
he was like i think you should come to
on-site i think you should do this
program
you know and it was just all these
things that i kept
like i i reached like i was saying
before i reached out to everybody i
could think of to like help me
get better and figure my way through
this well it sounds like things were
falling into place and i always feel
like to me those are like
winks from the universe that things are
in there are going
correctly like whether it be seeing the
numbers on the phone that are like
you know five five five or four four
four or eleven eleven or whatever it is
or whether or not you're you're doing
something you thought oh whoops i didn't
mean to
oh i'm so glad that happened because
then i did this and i met this person
or like for me i always feel like so i
noticed this in the grocery store all
the time i'll be like
pushing my card around and i love
grocery shopping but i'll be pushing my
card around all sudden i'll be like
called to like call go down an aisle or
think i forgot something or went the
wrong way and i'm always grabbing
something i'm like i totally forgot to
write that down
right i forgot i needed that and like
things like that
so believe that don't like those are
easy because they're like
easy to accidentally go down the wrong
aisle or take one extra drive down
but but let that be the let that be the
seed
to bigger things of trusting your
intuition and signs
and gut feelings and things like that
because
you know we really have a lot more of an
understanding i think for what needs to
happen moving forward then we
give ourselves credit yeah and i think
the gut feeling thing is so true and
it's so
easy it's it's such a fine line right i
feel like it's so easy to not pay
attention to your 100
it's just it's so subtle right and it's
like i
feel like when i don't any time in my
life or i haven't really trusted my gut
and i haven't gone with what i felt it's
always the wrong decision you know and
it's so
it's such a you know how many people
hear that me or anybody hears that and
they go
[ __ ] yeah because there's always
something going on where you're like
yeah you know it's like it you know it's
like this it's
it's so interesting the things that our
mind does and
i and i and i you know i i listen to and
i read a lot of things about this
stuff now because i'm so fascinated by
it and how our our egos
you know and our minds it's like the
thing with like don't think of a pink
elephant and you think of a pink
elephant like why do our minds
why can't they just listen to us you
know it's like our mind they are though
yeah yeah i mean you should do have you
listened to joe dispenza or
greg braden or bruce lipton yeah
they'll talk about all this stuff but
there's there's a lot of um
you know there are our bodies hormonally
get conditioned to the stimulant
of a trauma of a negative thought and
we're addicted to that hormonal response
i believe that
and um and that can be really
perpetuating yeah and then over time we
end up
re reforming that thought into being
something that isn't even
really real anymore well i feel like
that's a lot of like what you know i
learned a lot in therapy is like
the stories we make up in our minds
versus like what's the reality
sure i feel like someone once said to me
that your intuition
can be broken and i was like oh
definitely mine's broken or it was you
know where you think that like
you know you're you're so turned around
that you're like making odd decisions
because your intuition is not
leading you the right way well you're
probably listening to the ego side
there's another
semi saying where i i i have a hard time
getting these things exactly right
but good thanks sympathy
but uh it's like the
the ego is is is has an
urgency because it knows its time is
limited
and the soul is patient because it knows
it has eternity ah that's so good
and so that's the subtleness that's like
i only operate out of love i don't make
you scared you're making the right
choice i only operate out of love
we're where the ego operates out of fear
and security
and it just goes deep and it's hard and
it's loud it's so
loud and i think you know that's the
thing when you ask like what i've
learned you know it's like i'm i'm
learning
learning because like right we're always
learning it's like i think i'm learning
to not operate out of fear
i think that's a big thing for me it's
like to not do something because i'm
scared
of something else you know and that that
has been a big learning for me
like is there something is an example of
something that you said yes to that
you're like i wouldn't have done that
well i think it's like i think
everybody and i don't know if this was
true for you when and i did first get
divorced everybody was like
you need to take a year i'm like a year
and not date like a year and not date
and just like
spend time working on yourself i was
like nope
nope not doing that i was like i hate
that advice but
everybody said that you need a year wow
to go through it
listen either i know and i was like and
i think it was like
for me it was like this fear that if i
don't start dating
i'm never gonna find the guy i'm gonna
expire
yes like there's some fear in me that's
like if you don't like
keep at it it's never gonna you know
validation i think it's like i also
approach it like i approach business
like i'm very
driven and i make [ __ ] happen and that's
just what i do so i'm like
why wouldn't it be the same with like
love and romance and like
really works the same you know i really
struggle this is like just a
confession like i do struggle to i'm
very nurturing and i love taking care of
people
but i have a look of an aggressiveness
to me and it's really hard for me to
like operate from a really soft space
consistently very like is that why
you're
a great race car driver do you have
probably intensity probably
yeah and why the show's called pretty
intense because that's who
that's my that's my natural energy and
you know i was just talking about this
with my friends too the other day that
um you know in relationships so
someday when you know if you haven't
already met him again met them
met the you know a new love of your life
but they'll be
um they'll be that person and you'll
have
you'll have issues because it you just
will of course 100
yeah and that is just because that's who
you are like so for me it's like slow
down like i will always struggle to slow
down
and just relax and not take things so
seriously
and so in a relationship these can be a
problem right because they're
they're they're a reoccurring issue
and we lose that ability to remind each
other hey you're getting better at it
because guess what
it never is going to be gone right
because it is who you are
yeah so i said if i can go from being
someone who's like 10 out of 10 intense
super drip like wait pushing too hard
aggressive
never slow down and if i can end my life
at a three
yeah i did a really really good job yeah
so
it's like it's recognizing those aspects
of us
that are just who we are innately and
our our natural energy and
just our just our our our our soul's
personality expression
yeah that we just go look like we just
we have to go like this is who i am
but you're getting better and you're
getting better because i think that can
be hard in a relationship i think it's
like you can recognize it you know
like for me i'm incredibly impatient and
i want things like
you know yesterday yes like why haven't
we done this and i
really don't understand and i think this
is right about like
when i'm driving and people are driving
slow i don't understand why you don't
have urgency like don't you have to
watch
somebody go yeah what like why are you
driving so slow and then every now and
again and it's funny because i was
driving up here i was like
i'm driving i'm driving slow what's
happening because i'm like
i'm looking at the water which you know
in l.a i'm like buzzing all around and
i'm usually late for everything
so it's like you need to move to the
coast i know like all the way to the
coast
i know and it's like that's the thing
for me it's like slowing down too it's
like
being you know being being so
impatient um and i also like recently
got a tattoo that means no expectations
because i think that's another thing is
that it's in french
it's another thing for me that i i
expect so much from other people
probably because i expect so much for
myself
yep and i'm like why aren't you do why
aren't you being the best that you can
be i'm trying to be the best and i can
be why aren't you doing this
and it'll be hard to understand why but
that's great yeah you're like we're
trying for that
yeah yeah and it's like in relationships
and things like well let's like
we're not getting any younger like let's
get on with this but then it's like well
you have to give it time and like my
best friend's always like you know
a flame needs air like you're burnt to
burn and i'm like
ah just light it you know so it's dating
then like
give me the oversight of dating is it
like weird ah to date again so
weird well i guess you're not dating
you've been in a relationship for a
while right i'm not very good at dating
i'm
i'm not good at dating either who's good
at dating much of a dater i'm
kind of like oh you're my human now for
a while yeah yeah you're my human but
but it's like how do you how did i mean
i don't know how you guys met but like
i'm like
where what do you do now where do you
people get on
dating apps now i mean i'm on a dating
app but it's
weird it's weird i agree
it's not weird in the real world but so
hang on so
look like one of the things that's come
up too lately is like what are repeating
patterns
and while you probably don't have a
really good rolodex of like um
or a a beta test of repeating patterns
as you
really were with one person for a very
long time but
looking forward based on
what you've learned and where you're at
what do you what are some
what are some core values that you're
just not willing to compromise on
again well i think that's i think sure i
learned a lot in my marriage
but and i and i think you know the
marriage
probably should have ended sooner than
it did um and i think what i
what i've learned in the last year
through dating and learning about myself
is like you have to like you know you
can't let things
linger and drag on when they're not
right
and and honestly i think that goes for
everything in your life when you realize
there's something that you're doing that
isn't
working you gotta like even if it's hard
to like say like nope not gonna do this
or i'm not gonna be treated that way or
i'm not gonna let somebody
do that then you have to like nip those
things in the butt i think that's
that's the pattern i realized of myself
in the last year
was kind of letting myself kind of get
dragged through things that weren't
good or healthy for me and now i'm like
know your indicators
um i think when it's like i think when
i guess it's like you know being more
communicative and
and knowing that you know like you know
i'm not to go back to dating but it is
like it's been really interesting to me
like dating and being like
yeah no this isn't going to work because
you're not because i can see
that you're not going to be this person
i need you to be and so i'm not gonna
initially i was wasting my time and just
kind of like well i just i'm gonna make
it work we're gonna figure it out nope
you know it's like you have to like
really know what you want and what you
need
you know for yourself and i think that's
true you know what do you need and
i mean i well now we're getting really
personal
well i mean other than sex what do you
need well you know
that's easy yeah that's the easy part
the sex
yeah yeah yes well that there that was
sort of missing for me too
um i think you know for me it's like i
need somebody who first of all i think i
need somebody who's very strong and
confident
yeah um and i think for who i am what
i've done with my life
yeah it's it's i have found that it's a
little intimidating yeah it's a big life
to men i mean i'm sure you've probably
experienced that too although you know
it's like you need somebody who can like
hang with you and someone who's not
intimidated and emasculated found that
to be okay
you know it's like you can't god that's
not gonna work you know
um you know and someone's in like the
same like like place i am and
you know there's this like you know i'm
really like i've learned that i really
love like
an old-fashioned kind of guy who's like
very chivalrous and
like i think because i've always been
the one
who is like the boss and takes
care of everything you don't want to be
in charge dude you don't want to be in
charge not in a relationship it's
actually how it is for me too i
took a personality test and part of it
was in a relationship
i actually don't want to be in charge i
don't know and i'm like yeah
like i really do please don't take
advantage of the fact that i'm so
nurturing and like want to take care of
you because i will
but like i want like respect me for that
right because i but
it's weird because it doesn't seem like
it would fit my personality
because i'm so strong and so driven and
i am so used to you know just having the
answers and figuring the things out and
that's just who i
am it's about balance though yeah but
the only time
and i realized that wasn't like the case
in my marriage which i realized
ultimately wasn't right for me you know
it's like i want
you know i like and i and it's and it's
like a polarizing topic because
the world has shifted like everyone's so
independent
everybody like women and i think and i
i've
i've been on panels before where you
know with women where i'm like listen
i realize that there's some really bad
guys out there who've done some really
bad things
but they're not all bad and my my
business partners are both men and
they're really good guys the ceo of my
company is a man and he's amazing you
know i'm like there's really
good guys out there too you know and it
drives me a little bit crazy that
there's this like you know it's like
let's just be
equal in terms of like you know the
whole like it doesn't have to be
all women i don't think it should be i
think there should be a balance you know
and so i think for
for dating and being you know figuring
out what you need it's like i want a guy
to take care of me
in in that emotional way you know i
don't need him to take care of me
in other words i want someone to treat
you like a queen right
and you'll treat him like a king
probably too yes right
not a matter of like you know
some old outdated 50s rolls of
you know a couple it's like no i i just
want to be a queen like and i want my
king
yeah like open the doors for me yeah you
know where that's gonna cry i'm a big
like
like surprised me i love surprises like
i love like being
being like the unexpected you know yeah
me too
yeah and i think that the root of all of
it really like you know to have that
deep connection and that respect for
each other because if you're gonna play
certain roles that you really want and
if you want some chivalrous and if you
want to
you know not have to be so in charge
like the the connection
underneath it all is the vulnerability
it's that vulnerability
of saying how you really feel and not
holding back even if it's really nice
because sometimes we hold back the
really nice
because we're like because we're like oh
they don't want to hear it again or oh
maybe they're not feeling that much as i
am right now
but just to really go there and if
they're not
going to meet you there then you're
already getting your information and
it's
better to be sooner than later i mean
and that's that's something i've learned
is like you know
get the information get is gather as
much information about
somebody as you can i mean i think you
know for for me with dating it's like
oh you know i mean somebody was recently
dating it's like i realized they were
like not ready to be in a relationship i
was like oh well then
i gotta go because that's what i want
you know it's like and so you have to
like know what you need and what you're
not
what you want and i think it's
interesting too how it translates into
when i think about into business and all
like the you know the people who have
worked for us you know and like when
they they needed something else it's
like and they would be afraid to say i'm
not happy in what i'm doing right now
because they're they're afraid to tell
their boss i'm like
or tell me i'm like just tell me and
we'll fix it and we'll figure it out
we're not no one's getting fired like
we're not gonna do anything crazy like
if you're not happy doing
you know marketing for their shops and
you would rather be do
marketing for the products like let's
talk about it that doesn't mean that
it's gonna happen
in that second but you know it's like
and i think that's the thing is like i
think people are afraid
in all aspects of life to say what they
really want for fear
that it's going to backfire on them and
perhaps it does
i feel like we still do it similar
because what i'm feeling right now is
that
you believe in your companies you
believe in your products you believe in
that
yeah you believe it wholeheartedly so
the communication is not offensive
because you just want
you just want the best yeah and in a
relationship
there's some part of you and this is
some part of me that i've had to deal
with too that doesn't believe
that you're going to get it or you
deserve it oh yeah yeah i'm
firmly in that unfortunately so if you
don't believe then all you're going to
do is sabotage right because you don't
believe and things aren't going to go
right
so as soon as you believe that that is
what you're going to get and that is
what you deserve and you are
worthy of all of those wonderful things
then that is exactly what you're going
to get
yeah but how do you get yourself to
believe um
that is that is who has that answer that
is and honestly the journey is to the
self
yeah yeah the journey really itself it's
not about someone
um someone or something outside of you
filling you up if you can get to the
point where absolutely nothing is
necessary outside of you to fill you up
you're you're getting really close very
shamany of you yeah
true but it's like i think this is
what's lost in like religion versus
spirituality or self
you know the sort of self-reflection
stuff is that when
when you're doing the spirituality or
like i feel like even spirituality is
getting like pigeon holed into this bad
space but
it's really about self-reflection it's
more of that
um buddhism kind of attitude of like the
self
and that is where it's all at there was
a great
a great ramdas quote that i saw and
that's i love ramadan
yeah that that that the only i i've
literally looked at this like five times
i'm like why can't i get this quote
right
as our we we can relate on the not
getting the quotes right it says
there's nothing you can do for me but
work on yourself
there's nothing i can do more for you
than work on myself and so if you don't
work on yourself
and get yourself right get your [ __ ]
together
get confident get comfortable not need
me essentially
then it all works we're gonna
frequencies are gonna sync up with the
right person yeah and it's gonna be easy
yeah also gonna be it's not gonna be
it's never gonna be easy
but it's just you're always going to be
dealing with well you can't and i hope i
think i've learned that too is like you
can't look to somebody else for your
happiness it's
going to come from with you yeah the
validation the simple little validation
like
simple things like you say i love you
and they're like they don't say it back
like oh god it's like matter wait a
second i offered that
it's gone you don't have to say it for
me to for me to i don't talk i don't
want to
get the response i'm not here for the
response i'm here yeah it's not give to
get
yes correct my do you ever listen to
rachel hollis you know
yeah she's great she's great and i feel
like relatable i just was listening to
something she said
just that like this whole like theory of
like i am love
like i'm gonna come at you with all of
my love and not to your point for you to
say
you know i love you back yeah it's just
like and and and
and i have to give my ex-husband a lot
of credit because i remember him saying
that to me before like sometimes if i'd
say something nice and
he wouldn't respond to it if he was like
on text or something he's like it was so
nice to receive that
i was like busy and whatever but it like
made me happy and smile but i didn't
you know it's like don't send it you
can't send something out into the world
with the expectation that you're gonna
get it back you know it's like you have
to just
put it out there because you want to put
it out there and then like that's it yep
and that's a tough yeah it's tough it is
a little hard like i was just sent like
a sweet message and i was like look i
i sent him a text and i was like i just
send when i have strong feelings and
like hits
like i just say them because you have to
like you have to follow the intuition so
the more
the more you can sort of the more you
can respond to that intuition that as
you said so simply it's so hard to hear
sometimes
the better you'll get at hearing it and
the better you'll get at responding to
it
yeah it's a journey man so what are you
going to
um what what are what are like what are
the core values you want to instill in
your boys after all the things that
you've learned in your life because
you've had a big life
yeah yeah you know learned so far and
it's okay to expand on it as time goes
because that's life
i mean i think i want i want my boys to
grow up with this like
you know i can do anything i want i want
my boys to grow up thinking
they should they should follow what
makes them happy
not what they think society tells them
they should be doing
amen you know i really want my kids to
have that like
freedom emotional like freedom to just
be and do what they want and i really
think a lot of that comes from like my i
think my parents
allowed that for me and they let me like
try the things i wanted to do and there
was there was never a lot of judgment
and
really any judgment you know and i think
i want my kids to grow up
in that same you know
vein of like yeah any any anything's
possible you can try anything
but you know but also like you know my
my 14 year old son really wants he's
really into music and he really wants to
be a rapper and
he's the next choice but
but it's kind of what he wants to do and
i fully support it but i'm like
but i just then the practical side of me
comes out and says but you know perhaps
if that doesn't
it's hard to do that it's it's like one
in a million
to make it at that level perhaps you can
but even
you know you're learning how to produce
music and maybe that's something that
you end up doing too
you know so but if you ever read the
alchemist
i have it but i haven't read it you 100
[ __ ] really
and you know that story makes me think
of like just let him be the rapper then
and guess what maybe he'll end up
finding what he actually really wants on
the way to being a rapper yeah
you know i know i think that's like a
lesson i have to like learn that's
really the alchemist it's a great book
been around forever i also want my boys
to grow up um
you know i want them to be like good
men you know i think because i've seen
because of you know the state that we
live in and what i want you know i want
my boys to be really respectful to women
i want my boys to like you know have a
lot of respect for
yeah for for women each other and you
know my my kids are really
um especially my older son like he's
always like been the kid who sticks up
for
the kid that's getting bullied you know
and i think that you know my dad taught
me that too he's like if you get
suspended for sticking up for somebody
that's funny okay
yeah exactly i think that's that's an
important thing
you know it's like and then i just
you're like i was always in trouble my
kids are um
like you know but my kids are very uh
they get a lot of their like hutzpah i
would say you know i think from
from me because i'm like i mean very
like outspoken like not afraid to speak
up and say what they think which you
know can get them in trouble like yeah
you know i was loud and a little
obnoxious in school and i would like go
for the laugh and i was like a little
bit attention seeking which
isn't surprising now i was like about to
work
real similar yeah and my kids are like
that too and
um you know and it's also hard i mean i
also want to get on a tangent but like
you know i don't know if you ever are
going to have kids but like you know the
things that kids are taught in school
and it feels very antiquated to me and
it's a little bit frustrating and i wish
that there was like you know i know i
keep going back to it but
having gone through what i've gone
through in the last year or so
you know the fact that like kids are not
equipped to deal
with what they're being thrown at in the
world of like you know this like crazy
like instagram and social media and all
the [ __ ] that they're dealing with like
kids should be taught like mental health
i think it's probably i've shot
almost 30 episodes now the show and i
would say that in
i'd say two-thirds at least half of the
shows
we talk about curriculum in school yeah
because
there's just it's so it's so outdated
there's just no
like the real tools for life do you
fricking
need geometry yeah seriously no i mean
no
my kids say to me and i was i was
terrible in school like i just wasn't i
mean neither one of us went to college
like i just and look
we did pretty well did okay yeah
millions of reasons why it worked out
it's like i didn't and my sons will say
to me like i don't
care about this how how does this matter
in my life and
i don't have an answer for you right i
will say
i what i you want to say i agree i do
say i agree and
because i that's the other thing with my
children i've always been very like
we're very
real with our kids and i think that's
important and i've said to my kids
unfortunately it's something it's a
means to an end and you have to do it
i don't agree with it and i don't think
you're necessarily learning what you
need to learn for life in school you're
going to learn that in other ways
but you have to do this and you have to
show up and you have to just go yeah
i think what school does do you know is
teach responsibility
and that's what i say judgment that's
what you take away
you learn how to deal with people and be
social and like be respectful
yep and be on time yep and that kind of
stuff but
i don't think you need to you know
without going to recess you could do
that going to a meditation class you
could do that going to
uh a manifestation class you can do that
going to
let's i mean we laugh at home act but
let's let's face it if you learn how to
cook that change your life it keeps you
healthy keeps you away from disease
yeah um let's stop laughing at boiling
water and making cupcakes like
this is the kind of stuff that is
actually going to be play into your life
it's funny how to wash clothes yeah i
mean
and i think that like the things that
like the whole like you know like to
your
home you know that i think there's like
probably a lot of
boys out there that would like to know
how to cook but it's like
frowned upon in school because it's like
a girl thing which like look how many
male chefs there are
mostly yeah like like when you think
about famous chefs a lot like
most of them are messed up yeah actually
i've interviewed a bunch of them they're
all men
yeah i mean there's just you know i
think it's just it's so broken
and it's hard to see your kids going
through that and like
this like you know it's finding the
lesson in that right i guess that's the
best you can do is say
yeah you know in life sometimes it's not
always easy sometimes it doesn't really
make sense
but sometimes you have to find the
positive in it and you have to go look
at least i'm learning how to
bite my tongue i'm learning how to yeah
you know i'm learning how to deal with
things
like my younger son is really into
skateboarding and he goes to like a
skate park every day of his life and
he's so
focused on that and he's also like off
the charts adhd has such a hard time
focusing in school
but he's so focused in skateboarding and
he loves it so much and he's like
working so hard at it and i'm like
great we fully support it like well look
look how his
dis ease yeah is yeah serving him yeah
he really wants to do something he does
he knows how to get it done
right he can get it done he can he's
like i don't want to sit
in a chair in school i was like i know
but i wish you didn't have to
you know wow well there's so much to
navigate in life and you know we're
like i mean you know what it's kind of
like and then the question comes up like
what's the point of all of it right
what's the point of life and
and and and and and let it feel good
that it's about that journey yeah
let the journey feel like the like let
there be joy in it and realize that like
it's not always gonna feel good but once
you get
through it that fun part that you don't
like that no one likes by the way so
it's not just you nobody likes to cry
nobody likes to feel horrible nobody
likes to be confused nobody likes to
feel alone
nobody but once you get through you're
stronger and you keep doing that and all
of a sudden
you know you're zeus yeah you know and
it's in it's interesting how
what the things the the another lesson
i've learned is like
the the you can't have the good without
the bad and you can't you can't have the
bad
good and that's that's the in terms of
like what's it all for
you know the dualities of life it's a
polarity lows it only comes with like
just as much as like i've heard this you
know i heard it said where
you know people are talking about how
bad the world is and how awful it is
and then there's the other side it's
like yeah but look at the look at the
conversation that you and i are having
right now
yeah was this happening 20 years ago
right no probably not really like little
tiny little pockets of the world here
and there with monks on the top of
mountains
like you know or you know very small
little spots but look at the evolution
so
again it's about the duality of life the
light and the dark side like we have to
we have to face both of them they're
both a reality and it's how we deal with
that's how you learn and grow
exactly we can't we can't it can't all
be roses and sunshine that's right
yeah i'm gonna die for that and i'm not
ready yeah exactly
all right well thank you so much what a
cool conversation i know i feel like i
could stay here for hours yeah okay so
anyway next topic is
about uh transition and vulnerability
you
know
thank you yeah that was really good um
you're
you've got it more figured out than you
think you do and um
yeah you know trust that and trust
yourself and and
um you know if it if you ever for a
moment wonder just
look at look at what you've done so far
just look like have a little perspective
yeah you're amazing it's good advice
thanks
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you